Trump is a difficult to understand
genius hello and welcome to trigonometry
I'm Francis Foster I'm Constance and
kissin and this is a show for you if
you're bored with people arguing on the
internet over subjects they know nothing
about a trigonometry we don't pretend to
be the experts we ask the experts our
fantastic guest this week is a writer
economist and a former CIA adviser Jim
Rickards welcome to trigonometry Thank
You Konstantin thank you it's great to
be here well you you're a writer and an
author of a number of books the latest
of which is aftermath which is this get
it it's a brilliant read and Jim before
anyone who doesn't know who you are tell
us briefly who are you how are you where
you are what has been your journey
through life well it's not clear whether
my career path is could be described as
eclectic or I just couldn't decide what
I wanted to be when I grew up but it's
been emotional I'm a lawyer by training
but spent most of my career on Wall
Street I work for commercial banks
investment banks hedge funds stock
exchanges etc along the way after 9/11 I
was tapped by the CIA to help them with
financial threats and financial warfare
and what we call market intelligence or
markand
became a big subject inside the CIA has
not been previously during the Cold War
I mean Russia were a Soviet Union we're
not in capital markets so that wasn't
part of the battlespace but it certainly
is today and they do a good job of
outreach when when they they kind of
know what they don't know and they bring
in people so I did that for for a long
time and then starting in 2011 I had my
first book currency wars and the new
book aftermath and thank you for
mentioning that is is actually volume
four of an international monetary
quartet so it was currency wars the
death of money the road to ruin and
aftermath had these nice cheery titles
yeah
it's a it works as a quartet actually
I'll talk to my publisher at some point
about a a box and get all four and one
one nice slip case but the aftermath
completes the quartet is it's the new
book and we're kind of on the road
explaining it to people and talking
about it
see Constantine has got a background in
economics I don't and I found it very
very accessible and I found it very very
informative and I love the metaphor you
use at the start how the essentially the
u.s. is trying to navigate when you used
the metaphors of monsters from ancient
Greeks killer and so if you could go
into a little bit about that and explain
what these two threats are that the u.s.
is now facing sure and that was actually
the most difficult part you're right
it's it's really a challenge when you're
writing about economics most economists
don't write books they write articles
and academic papers and give
presentations and all that it's hard to
write a book about economics because
either you do a textbook which I
definitely did not want to do and it's
not a textbook fortunately but because
economics tends to be very contemporary
market driven etc a book becomes stale
very quickly after its published so the
challenge is can you write a book in
economics that's interesting
that has a good shelf life that you can
pick it up ten years later and say hey
there's still something here for me or
something I can learn from that's what I
try to do and I will say my first book
currency wars in 2011 it's still selling
extremely well all the books her parents
did none of them have gone out of print
and it's got a second or third life
because we're in we're in a currency war
die I said in 2009 or 2011 when the book
came out that we're not always in a
currency war but when we are it can last
10 or 15 or 20 years so I'm not
surprised here we are in you know 2019
and the currency wars are still going on
so so that book did it and then the
other books the same thing so Francis
with particular regard to your point so
what did the Fed do you know 2008 and we
will talk a little bit more about that
you know cut interest rates to zero
expanded the balance sheet from eight
hundred billion dollars to four point
five trillion dollars that's how much
money the Federal Reserve printed and
all the other major
central bank's Bank of England People's
Bank of China did the same things this
was a global phenomenon talking about
quantitative easing when Italian is a
so-called chewy
there was qe1 qe2 qe3 as I say printed
took the balance sheet up to four and a
half trillion dollars but they at some
point they had to get back to normal now
maybe we've lost sight of what normal is
maybe that's interest rates of you know
three or four percent which would be a
little more normal and getting the
balance sheet down to maybe two trillion
is it's it's an inexact science but if
the Fed got interest rates to four
percent got the balance sheet down to
two trillion I would be the first one to
say nice job guys you save the world
from a worse outcome in 2008 you got
everything back to normal and you're
ready for the next recession that is not
what happened what happened is they're
still stuck rates are close to zero
they're going down again after going up
for the last couple years they're going
down again the balance sheet has not
come down has come down very little
maybe around three point nine trillion
although it's going up again so what
happened was the Fed was trying to again
get rates up get the balance sheet down
to get ready for the next recession but
the the sill and Charybdis metaphor was
in in in the course of preparing for a
recession would you cause a recession by
avoiding one danger where you're selling
into another danger and that was the
feds conundrum and I said several years
ago they would not be able to do it that
in fact they would cause a recession in
the course of doing this and that's
exactly what happened we got very close
so at the end of 2018 j-pal or Fed
Chairman got a wake-up call it's like oh
I've tightened too much I shouldn't have
tightened in December of 2018 they're
raising interest rates we are very close
to recession and the US was at the end
of 2018 so he quickly reversed course
said first we're not going to raise
rates anymore and we'll tell you if we
do you know we'll give you advance
warning so you won't be caught by
surprise then by the spring he said well
actually going to cut rates which they
did in June and September of 2019 and
then finally they had reversed cutes
QE quantitative easing I still run into
people I'm tired of the Fed printing
money we hate quantity and I said they
know they stopped that in 2014
they've been
burning money since then since 2017-2018
the Fed trying to reduce the balance
sheet you may remember there was a
famous cartoonist show a manic looking
at Ben Bernanke hanging from the strut
of a helicopter throwing money that was
the image of Hillary copter money well
instead picture Jay Powell with a pile
of hundred-dollar bills a shovel
throwing money into a furnace that's
what they've been doing they've been
reducing the money supply well this was
a double dose of tightening higher rates
reduced money supply almost through the
economy into a recession they've
reversed course on both now rates are
coming down again they're printing money
again and by the way we're we're in QE
four they won't call it that but the Fed
is printing a trillion dollars of new
money as of the fall 2019 so call what
you wanted it's Q before so my point was
on the one hand you have to get ready
for the next recession on the other hand
are you going to cause a recession that
was so encrypted
they were trying to sell down the middle
and avoid both dangers as I said they
would not be able to do it they're gonna
have to choose the enemy or choose the
danger if you will and they did they
said we're going to avoid recession but
it means they have thrown in the towel
and normalizing so at the higher level
means they're not ready for the next
recession so essentially what you're
saying is and again layman's terms is we
have a debt or the US have a debt that
is too big for them to service correct
that I am saying that that's it that's a
separate issue let's separate monetary
policy and fiscal policy so monetary
policy is the central bank you know
raising or lowering rates printing money
or reducing the money supply so that's
the world of monetary policy over here
debt deficits and and the budget that's
fiscal policy they are related because
that where it really gets a little
tricky and a little dangerous is if you
tell the government's they can spend as
much as they want and we're as much debt
as they want what's the discipline on
that well the discipline is the market
if the market says hey we don't want
your paper anymore we're not buying it
or interest rates go up that tends to be
self-limiting what if the Federal
Reserve is sitting over here saying hey
no problem guys you shoot it and we'll
buy all the debt we want all
that you want with printed money that's
now your monetizing the desk so that's
where fiscal policy was just debt and
deficits monetary policy which is money
printing come together if the Federal
Reserve monetizes the u.s. debt so both
things are an issue and but but
specifically to the Fed their failure
was they could not get back to normal
without causing recession which means
they're not ready for the next recession
on the fiscal side we're at least in the
our states were back to the wonderful
world of trillion-dollar deficits less
less seen in 2011 we'll get into that
because you one of the things you
outline very well in the book that
essentially historically the pattern in
the United States is that you borrow in
times of war and then you repay in times
of peace and we used to do that we have
not been doing that and one of the
interesting things that I ranked true
with me is that no one is talking about
fiscal conservatism anymore that is that
is a phrase that used to be a
centerpiece of political discussion
correct I have not heard that for for
ten years probably close to ten years
and I think that's quite telling because
as you mentioned in the book the the
u.s. now has a debt which is bigger than
his GDP right and it's and its problem
at it's not just big it is in your
absolute very constant so concerned
about deficits the United States you
know last seen in 2010 that was the rise
of the Tea Party so-called and you know
a conservative Republicans worried about
debt and deficits and they took over the
Congress they the Republicans took our
House of Representatives and and they
they got the Senate later it on the on
the strength of that and a lot of those
members are still around but now that we
have a Republican president they seem to
have forgotten all about fiscal
discipline it was they were opposed to
Democrats spending more where they
seemed okay with Republicans spend
anymore but the way I look at it I try
to keep partisan politics out of it I
have my opinions like everyone else but
I'm looking at Republicans and Democrats
in this together and kind of what you
said constantine about the history 230
years of the government bond market the
history is the debt to GDP ratio how
much debt
relative to the size of the economy goes
up in times of war and down and gets
repaid in times of peace so it hasn't
been you know straight up since George
Washington to Donald Trump it looks more
like a sine wave it goes up and down
like this until 2000 that's when things
run off the rail when Bill Clinton left
office the national debt was five
trillion dollars after eight years of
George Bush it had doubled to ten
trillion dollars in eight years of Obama
it had doubled again to twenty trillion
dollars and Trump has thrown a couple
trillion dollars on top of that so I say
we we used to have bipartisan
responsibilities today we have
bipartisan irresponsibility it's not
specifically a democrat or republican
issue as I said both parties are
spending freely let's look at basically
what you're essentially saying is the
patient had a heart attack we've emptied
the medicine cupboard we haven't
restocked it well and before we get on
to that we kind of started with a
slightly different order but I want you
just for ordinary people who may be
watching this just briefly summarize for
us why did the 2007-2008 crash happen
well the reason it happened is fairly
straightforward and for that we can go
back a little further in time to 1998
that was the Russian default we had a
global financial crisis we had a global
liquidity crisis it was over somewhat
quickly and it did not lead to a
recession but it was just as dangerous
as what happened in 2008 and it at all
you know start in Thailand went to
Indonesia and Korea and Russia but it
ended up in my lap at a hedge fund in
Greenwich Connecticut called long-term
capital management and I was their chief
lawyer I I was not the head of the risk
management committee unfortunately but I
say when when people mess up badly
enough he gets dumped on the lawyers so
here was a situation where this fund had
lost four billion dollars in about five
weeks and people said well okay you know
too bad for you guys or too bad for your
investors but who on earth wants to bail
out a hedge fund that's not our job and
if you're this fed and that's what we
thought we said well too bad for us but
no one's going to bail us out but we we
called the Fed to explain what was
happening
just to be good corporate citizens we
said well we you know we see a train
wreck we want to we're in it we want to
tell you about it but we weren't asking
for bail nor do we expect one but when
the Fed realized that we had 1.3
trillion dollars of derivatives swaps
and options with the 14 biggest banks
they said hey if you guys go out you're
gonna take down these banks and that is
what would have happened
interestingly in 98 the first victim
would have been Lehman Brothers they
ended up being the first victim in 2000
2008 but they were always kind of the
weak sister of the group you know all
along that was always true so so the Fed
organized a bailout they didn't do it
themselves there was no government money
used but they were they did what's
called the convening power they got the
bank's together we put a package
together five days no one slept who
worked around the clock we got it done
and in effect Wall Street took over our
balance sheet with their own money
unwound it slowly over the course of a
year and the whole thing went away my
point is people forget about that I was
21 years ago and people again I can't
remember that or if you're younger you
maybe never heard of it but we was
living in Russia as I said I did on the
bailout but we were hours away from the
sequential closure of every stock in
bond market in the world that's how
dangerous it wasn't that so close to us
now when when you had that kind of
danger and it doesn't happen the plane
doesn't crash people tend to shrug it
off but as an insider sitting there with
the Fed and the Treasury and the head of
Goldman Sachs and JP Morgan then that
there's and they're lawyers and those
are the people we were up against and we
did get it done um we all understood the
seriousness of it it was a deal that no
one wanted to do and everyone had to do
so so then what was the the aftermath of
that if you well well the lessons I
learned in the lessons I think everyone
should have learned is yeah let's get
rid of derivatives you know not all of
them this but most of them let's have
more transparency let's have less
leverage
let's keep banking and and the
investment banking separated as they
have been under our glass-steagall law
for 80 years which worked very well and
the government policy response was the
exact opposite
they repealed glass-steagall they all of
a sudden law commercial banks and
investment banks to be in the same
business so it turns Citibank into a
hedge fund for example all the conflicts
that had existed in the 1920s we're back
again they repealed regulations on swaps
all of a sudden you could just swap so
on everything including oil this which
led straight to Enron which was a
massive collapse in the early 2000s so
it so is the 2008 crisis was approaching
2005 2006 I'm watching this and it's
like I'm watching the same movie I'd
live through it you know live the horror
show of long-term capital management I'm
seeing the same thing happened over
again now it was in mortgages so
so-called junk mortgages subprime and
similar types of a non credit worthy
mortgages the previous time had been in
the you know international bond markets
it doesn't matter that the catalyst can
come from a lot of places but what does
matter is that the system is so
interconnected and you have what's
called contagion where one sector or one
player goes down but they take other
people with them that's a domino effect
and it keeps spreading that's what we
had in 1998 it was truncated by this
bailout that's what we had in 2008 but
you know the first symptoms were in the
spring of 2007 and it was actually Hong
Kong Shanghai Bank in their u.s.
operation said you know our earnings
we're a little below expectations
because our mortgage losses were higher
than we thought everyone's like okay you
missed your earnings target but that was
it that was a red light that was hey
something's wrong in the mortgage market
something below the surface and then in
March 2007 Ben Bernanke famously said oh
this won't be a problem this will blow
over you know just one more example of
central bank's not understanding what
they regulate and then in the spring or
sorry the summer of 2007 you had the
equivalent of a heart attack where
associate Asian Rahl in France their
money market funds were closed and then
the Fed had to cut the discount rate and
then that the crisis began really a year
before the acute stage was September
2008 Lehman Brothers goes bankrupt Arg
gets bailed out etc but it started in
the summer of 2007 with
early warning in the spring of 2007 so
was mortgage-related of course and I'll
give you a very concrete example there
were a trillion dollars of subprime
mortgages these are mortgages that you
know no documentation don't have to
prove your income very non credit worthy
but there was a it was a bubble
mentality of frenzy and everyone hey buy
a house and borrowed money fix it up
sell for twice as much walk away with
rich you know and everybody was doing it
and was a trillion dollars worth now
what mortgage default rates rarely get
above five percent five percent is
really high in the mortgage market so
people were saying as smart people like
Ben Stein the financial analyst but the
central bank and others right well okay
let's get crazy let's assume a twenty
percent too far right which is which has
never happened but it's assumed that's
true one of trillion dollars of subprime
mortgages the twenty percent default
rate would be a two hundred billion
dollar loss which was only slightly
higher than the S&L crisis of the 1980s
you know just a for inflation it would
have been a comparable loss and the
attitude was well we survived the 80s
will survive this yeah that's bad banks
will take losses stock prices go down a
little bit but we'll survive what they
missed is yes there was one trillion
dollars of subprime mortgages but there
were six trillion dollars of derivatives
yeah that was invisible so all of a
sudden twenty percent of that was 1.2
trillion so you had so you have that
before anyone who doesn't know
derivative is essentially a way of
placing a bet on the future price of
something correct that's exactly it's a
side bet with no underlying so let's say
I borrow a million dollars of Francis
so we have a real Frances gives me a
million dollars I sign the note here's
that's the real transaction but then I
call you up and say hey Constantine you
want to make a little side bet on
whether I pay Frances back and like I'll
take the action and then we call
somebody else so you can so you create
your relatives out of thin air and
there's no limit on how many you can
have there off-balance-sheet meaning
give me the balance sheet of the company
I won't see them you have to read the
footnotes and then the the information
behind the footnotes so non-transparent
unregulated no limit on size and that's
what happened we he's gambling basically
it's just used to be illegal because of
gambling gambling laws those have been
around for on the books for a long time
so you had this trillion dollars of
subprime mortgages but about six
trillion dollars of exactly which side
that's so the crisis was actually much
worse than anyone realized and then when
it started to collapse the the contagion
spread throughout the financial system
and the scary thing is and what I gained
a lot from your book is that we haven't
learned the lessons of 2008 well that's
exactly right and my point about 2008 it
was because we did not learn the lessons
of 1998 and we flew right into 2008 but
once again we have not learned the
lessons of 2008 and we're going to fly
right into the next storm with one goes
I don't want my last year when's it one
distinction which is that in 1998 Wall
Street got together and bailed out a
head shrunk in 2008 the central banks
got together and bailed out Wall Street
who's going to bail all the central
banks and that was the point is each
crisis is bigger than the one before the
intervention gets elevated larger dollar
amounts and we now at the point where
there's no one left to bail us out
except the taxpayer yeah well although
the taxpayers are in near revolt as it
is so you're right that's that's the
ultimate source of money or Fed printing
yeah and you were sent you were talking
about you were saying in your book about
how actually what the this sort of black
hole of debt is student loans which blew
my mind
correct and
one of the questions of Espinoza
frequently is okay Jim I kind of follow
your analysis on how risk works and how
come
complexity theory and capital markets
how that works but where's the crisis
coming from what's going to be the
catalyst and that's the it's actually a
long list now student loans they're 1.6
trillion dollars worth of student loans
those this isn't the United States 50%
more than the subprime mortgage correct
but the default rates actually are 20%
again and I'm guessing they're not as as
much subject to derivatives as the
subprime mortgages well that's correct
but the the loss falls directly on the
taxpayer because they're all issued by
or guaranteed by the United States
Treasury now it ended up being the case
that the government had to get involved
in guarantee a lot in 2008 but at least
initially those mortgages were not
guaranteed by the government but the
student loans are so this will go and
kind of this gets to your point Frances
you know how does the out of capital
markets and money markets and Fed policy
kind of leech into to debt and deficits
so when you know a lender credit union
or anybody a university makes a loan to
a student and the Treasury guarantees
that loan which they do it's off budget
again it's it's it's not strictly
derivative but it is non transparent so
then the student defaults and the credit
unit the lender simply turns the
Treasury said here's here's your loan
file pay me and the Treasury pays the
lender because they've guaranteed the
loan analysis on the Treasury but until
that point that loss is not on the books
in our sis coverman that loss is not
part of the deficit but when the
Treasury writes the check to make good
on the guarantee it does go into the
deficit so we think deficits are high
now but there's this you know trillion
dollar tsunami of student loan losses
that's going to pile on top of the
structural deficits and make it even
worse so all these things are you know
I'm I spend all my time analyzing these
things I see them all I can describe
them I can see how they're going to
conversion into a worse crisis but in
the short run people either ignore them
or they just don't know anything about
them
should they I mean every day people
don't yeah although I just said when it
comes to around money everyone has a PhD
but pretty much right this is technical
stuff and people don't get it this is
why I like talking to you because you
can break think quite complicated things
down in a way that makes them accessible
I was going to ask just as a very quick
aside a few of the Democratic
presidential candidate Bernie in
particular they're talking about
canceling student debt so that would
take the off-balance-sheet
loss straight into the balance sheet
immediately and what do you think the
impact of a policy like that would be
well although two schools of thought my
my view is just disastrous and and I
could give a lot of reasons why but why
would Bernie Sanders even suggest that
by the way he's not long I think the
other candidates have you know Elizabeth
Warren and Joe Biden and Camilla Harris
one way or another have suggested that
they would do something similar that we
need Student Loan Relief and that ends
up going onto the budget and on to the
taxpayers but there's a School of
Economics and I talked about this in in
chapter 5 of my book it's called modern
monetary theory mmt for short just lost
half of you I wouldn't expect everyday
viewers every day people to know
anything about it but more to the point
economists don't know anything about
this is a new school of economics if you
want to think of it that way so it's
like which 1929 along comes John Maynard
Keynes with new theories on you know
aggregate demand whatever well there is
this modern monetary theory but the
leading light the leading scholar of
modern monetary theory is the lady named
stephanie kelton who's a professor of
the state university of new york but she
is the financial advisor to Bernie
Sanders 20 think I might have met HUD
kill Kannamma Keyser yeah yeah we
disagree on the theory but yes very nice
isn't this person very bright and she
was at Coco na mcc's but she's the
financial advisor to Bernie Sanders
right so this is where this is coming
from so you're right Bernie Sanders not
going to go to a you know a clambake in
New Hampshire or cookout in Iowa and
talk about modern monetary theory he
lives because that's what's behind the
thinking but what modern monetary theory
says is it actually there's no limit on
the amount you can spend you can spend
as much as you want
and the market water by the debt or if
they book the Fed will monetize the debt
and right now the US so how much debt is
there relative to the size of the
economy that this is called the debt to
GDP ratio but the way it's a simple
fraction you learn in the fifth grade
how much debt divided by the size of the
economy so in a simple example if you
had five trillion dollars of debt and a
ten trillion dollar economy that
fraction would be one-half so you would
say that that the GDP ratio is one half
or 50% today the debt is larger than the
economy that ratio is over a hundred
percent we had round numbers about 23
trillion dollars of debt and about a 22
trillion dollar economy so the ratio is
about a hundred and five percent highest
since World War two that troubles me it
troubles other economists but my friend
Stephanie says what's the problem you
could take it to 150 percent two hundred
percent two hundred and fifty percent by
the way that's where Japan is Japan's a
two hundred fifty percent Greece is one
hundred and seventy five percent or so
Italy's one hundred and thirty five
percent they're all still standing if
got it lately though you ought to go to
Italy the lights are on you know yeah go
to the Ginza you know it looks like
Times Square so you don't see visible
signs of stress and here's the irony Ben
Bernanke would absolutely not agree with
this theory and he said so publicly but
professor kellton says the Bernanke you
proved our point
you took you were the one who took the
Fed's balance sheet and quadrupled it
from eight hundred billion to four point
five trillion or so you prove that you
can print trillions of dollars of money
without causing inflation without
causing high interest rates without
causing a run on the bank so all we're
saying is you know you did it to prop up
Jamie diamonds bonus we wanted to do it
to forgive student loans
we may have we may have different policy
objectives but the process is the same
what's the problem now of all the things
I've debated on for years I was too
dragged into Bitcoin versus gold debates
which I thought were silly I mean I
don't like Bitcoin I do like gold but
it's like fish versus bicycles I mean
the debate never made sense to me even
though I did a lot of them but this of
all the things I've had to provide this
was actually the most difficult because
it's superficially appealing
first of all legally it is true that the
Fed can take their bounty as high as
they want there's no legal limit on the
feds ability to print money it is true
that Japan has a much higher debt to GDP
ratio and they're still standing it is
true that the Treasury can borrow as
much as they want subject to periodic
increases in the debt ceiling which have
never been denied and the Fed can
monetize the debt so all the elements of
the thesis are actually correct so how
do you refute it and the yet the answer
is that legally it can be done
and if your goal is to print a lot of
money and you know forgive student loans
or give a guaranteed job or guaranteed
basic income whatever it is in theory
you could do that but there is an
invisible psychological boundary and
this is what the modern monetary
theorists don't understand I don't think
Ben Bernanke understands it
there comes a time when people wake up
and they say you know I don't know
what's going on here I'm allowed to PhD
but get me out of the dollar it does and
so you know a buy Golub I'll buy silver
land oil natural resource a buy a new
car buy a house get me out of the dollar
into something tangible because I no
longer trust the monetary authorities I
no longer trust the Congress I can't
believe that you're gonna spend this
much money without sealing without limit
without causing inflation my
inflationary expectations will go up and
the way to deal with that is to buy hard
assets starting with gold but not
exclusively gold or as I say land real
estate and natural resources they're all
good they're all good substitutes at
that point interest rates will skyrocket
all of a sudden the bond market will
have difficulty selling it the you know
the president of Congress could take
away some of the feds independence all
these assumptions could come crashing
down very quickly very unexpectedly and
that's the problem with the theory Jim
there's a question that I want to ask it
it rages me every time why haven't we
learned lessons why do we make the same
mistakes again and again and again
great question then there there are two
reasons one is the the models that the
policy makers use are all wrong if you
have the wrong model you're gonna get
the wrong policy every single time so
what are the efficient market hypothesis
which it says that you can't beat the
market because markets get the
information faster than you do they
quickly and smoothly incorporated it
into the price yeah the price will go up
or down you can win or win or lose but
what you can't do is beat the market
because you can't you know think faster
then then the news is coming in the
market is a whole adjust that's not true
I mean we've had what how do you explain
crashes and panics how do you explain
situations where stock falls 20% in in a
minute which happens I hope for an
individual stock or for that matter
October 19 1987 the US stock market fell
22% in one day today by today's measure
on the Dow Jones Industrial Average that
wouldn't be 500 points that would be
5,000 points that happened on October
19th 1987 that's not efficient so my
point is that's a pillar of modern
financial theory but it's junk science
the Phillips curve you know there's an
inverse relationship between
unemployment and inflation so when
unemployment gets really low which it is
inflation has to go up false it's not
true unemployment is really low but
inflation is really low also so that's
junk science Value at Risk this is used
by all the big banks to manage their
risks and it you know basically says
that you know I don't have to look at
gross positions so I buy five billion
dollars swap from one person and I sell
the same five billion swap to another
person and I can net them down to my
risk is tiny because I'm long and short
the same amount
that's what value at risk would say you
don't need much capital for that tiny
little risk not true because what if
this guy goes bankrupt all of a sudden
this short position becomes oh that this
balance position becomes next short and
I gotta go out buy something to cover it
so so all these assumptions are wrong
but people cling to them and with wrong
assumptions wrong models you get bad
policy every time that's one reason the
other reason is just outright corruption
I was invited by the United States
Treasury to come down meet behind closed
doors with senior officials to give them
my view of how best to manage risk they
were very nice to invite me and had a
good audience and they were attentive
and there was a good opportunity nothing
changed but that sounds like being a
comedian no matter what you say
nothing's gonna change but in the middle
of the presentation to the senior
official who was there I have a habit of
interrupting myself and I was going
through risk and all that and I turned
to my said you know I don't envy your
job because the bank's own this town we
were in Washington should the bank's own
this town and I thought he would be
outraged and that's an insult what are
you saying whatever he no he looked at
me and said you're right meaning they
can't regulate in a way to control the
banking system because the bank
lobbyists and the banks themselves
control Washington what banker is going
to encourage the law rule or regulation
that reduces pay even by a nickel so
between the the Fed and the Treasury not
understanding risk because the models
are flawed and bankers pulling the
strings which they do and my wife hates
me to admit it but I was a registered
lobbyist at one point around in
Washington office I spent a lot of time
on Capitol Hill I I work behind the
scenes on exactly the kind of thing
we're describing so you eat on the right
model you can't see problems coming
you're not going to get the right laws
rules and regulations and it will keep
happening again but my point is every
time it happens it's worse than the time
before and does there come a time when
the crisis is so acute so big so out of
control and there is no one to bail it
out going back to what we said earlier
how can the Fed you know they've taken
their balance sheets of four trillion
they're back there printing money again
what are they gonna do next time five
trillion six trillion well my friends
Stephanie countless say yes and I would
say now because you're going to destroy
confidence and you talk about the
corruption where is that why we didn't
see top executives prosecuted in the
aftermath of the financial crash no
prosecutions no pay cuts no penalties
they're all back to their you know
twenty fifteen hundred million dollar
bonuses Jamie Dimon is a billionaire why
should a banker be a billionaire you
know if you're if you're you know you
create a Silicon Valley company or a
great app or you run a hedge fund there
they're like legitimate hard work being
a banker isn't one of them you should
have a nice pay in a nice retirement so
that's that's a pretty good example to
make it about me is I'm gonna work for
us it's just the jokes has to have some
basis in reality and yours done now what
Jim it's interesting to talk about all
this stuff and I guess the question I
was gonna ask you is some of your
detractors might say you have been
predicting a crash for a while right and
it hasn't happened right so is that
because it's just around the corner or
is that cause you're wrong
it's because it could be just around the
corner it could be deliberate but here's
the point just look at recent history
and I kind of start this from October
1987 you could go back further but
that's 1987 ladies that was really the
rise of derivatives the rise of linked
trading between the stock exchange and
the futures exchange there's a lot of
you know increased automation faster
telecommunication a lot of the things
we're still wrestling with today really
emerged in the late 80s and got more
intense in the 90s and through the 21st
century
October 19th 1987 stock market Falls 22%
Monday we managed to that 1994 the
Mexican tequila crisis the the
had to use a slush fund to Bill in
Mexico because our Congress said no 1997
the Asian financial crisis 1998 Russia
long-term capital management we talked
about that 2000 calm Nasdaq goes down
80% 2007 the mortgage crisis 2008 the
global financial crisis these things
happen every five seven years with some
regularity it's not you can't quite say
your watch by it but pretty close it's
been 11 years since the last one so who
wants to bet that it will never happen
again I just turned around on let's say
okay do you want to bet your net worth
your retirement your family's well-being
this will never happen again how do you
feel and then all they get some thinking
well maybe it will happen again and and
I wish to make the point that each one's
bigger than the last one so the next one
is going to be worse than you can
imagine something we've never seen maybe
since the 14th century who knows and
then I make another point which is
because people sort of say to me Jim
I've read your books I've heard your
presentations I actually it kind of
agree with what you're saying would you
mind calling me a 3:00 p.m. the day
before and I'll sell my stocks and buy
gold well first of all I'm not gonna
know the day I can I can with science
with very good you know kind of rigorous
support you can estimate the magnitude
of it and the fact that it will happen
timing it's the most difficult people
say well what good is it well it's like
an avalanche you know how does that work
well snow builds up and it builds up and
it builds up and an experienced
Mountaineer can look at that and say
that's going to collapse because there's
you know it's windswept the temperatures
to warm today you can see the Avalanche
is coming but it doesn't have to be
today or tomorrow or the day after but
do you want to ski under it do you want
to take that chance that you know
today's your lucky day Europe perhaps
your unlucky day and the other point I
make is that when this hits we'll know
it you know I'll know it you'll know
what the audience will know it it's
going to be too late to protect yourself
you're gonna say oh maybe I should get
some gold you know called the gold
dealer though well if you're not our
customers aren't gonna take your call
the dealers are going to be back ordered
the mints are going to be back ordered
gold is going to be going up $100 an
ounce a day not a week or a month but a
day
and you're gonna say get me some goal
and you won't be able to get it I want
to sell my stocks well yeah we care
they're down 40% you know you're welcome
to you lost half your money you notice
these things happen so quickly that when
people realize the the the panic is on
it will be too late to get out of losing
positions too late to preserve wealth
and so what I say to people is what are
you waiting for you know I'm not I'm not
saying that people you know when you're
in my position people have to put words
in your mouth ago Jim Rickards says you
know it's the end of the world sell
everything buy gold I've never said any
one of those things it won't be the end
of the world it could be a very
different world on the other side number
one and there are things you can do
today don't sell everything buy gold but
but have about 10 percent gold in your
portfolio it's like 10 quid how much
gold can you buy for 40 quid not much
[Laughter]
1,200 pounds per ounce so a fraction of
an ounce
Wow okay what does an ounce look like
physically well I also go what's
interesting about an ounce of gold it's
a it's a large coin its large large of
1,200 pounds they're exactly right the
the the classic British sovereign an i
occasion by sovereigns for as a
collectible it's it's not good value for
money in terms of gold and I understand
that naked my you know gold bullion or
coins or whatever for that purpose but I
do collect some gold coins and I have
some sovereigns they were seven grams
about a quarter ounce but what you know
I have a nice picture of King George the
fifth on one side George slaying the
dragon on the other side you know clad
but but 22 karat gold not 92% pure gold
they put in a little alloy you still got
your weight and gold but they're putting
a little alloy just to make it durable
because this was what we call
Philadelphia walking around money yeah
you you had in your pocket or your
person you would spend it and an ounce
was almost too much it was too much
value so the the quarter ounce was just
right and that was the classic British
sovereign but the point is the one ounce
coin a little bit larger in diameter
than coins we used today but
surprises people when you give them an
ounce two gold is the weight it's very
dense
it's one of the densest metals in the
periodic table the elements and people
it's kind of kind of heavy and they're
very impressed by them is pretty to the
fact that it's pretty it's not a reason
to have it retain value and it's scarce
and it checks all the boxes in terms of
a good form of money but people are
surprised at how heavy it is I've been
in some vaults where you know you see
these four hundred ounce bars to sort of
trap trapezoidal e shaped I want to lift
that bar up yeah it's 35 pounds it's
like if you get a freeway says farmers
it's kind of a kind of heavy to lift one
up and what about those people are
saying well I'm gonna be fine
I've got Bitcoin or whatever it is what
is your opinion on Bitcoin because it
only seemed like six months ago it was
that everybody was talking about it and
you know crypto and all the rest of it
yeah well Bitcoin just empirically
before we get into the substance of it
was the greatest bubble in the history
of the world as Bitcoin was going up so
now we're talking about the fall of 2017
it was going up I got thousand dollars
per coin per week it was 7,000 8,000
9,000 10,000 and I did an interview at
the time Mr Zuma early December 2017 and
I've never been a fan of Bitcoin don't
recommend it don't think anyone should
have it and the host s said well Jim
what's gonna happen I said well it's
gonna keep going up this is a bubble and
they go up until they don't so I could
see Bitcoin going into $20,000 and then
crashing straight down that's exactly
what happened
it went to $20,000 in the crash straight
down now you say oh well gee if I had
bought them for 10 bucks and it wasn't
that long ago when you quit about on for
10 bucks and they went to 20,000 and you
would sold them all you could have made
millions
I know people who did that there are
legitimate Bitcoin millionaires maybe
even a few Bitcoin billionaires I don't
doubt that those people are out there
and I even know some but the point I
make is that how did they make that
money this is a zero-sum game that came
out of the pockets of people who did pay
fifteen sixteen seventeen thousand
dollars South Korea and garage
coughs who hocked their inventory just
to buy a couple coins
you know Netherlands you know
middle-class individuals who sold their
houses and lived in trailers so they
could buy coins at these high prices
they've lost all the money they're in
suicides around that he's had blood on
your hands so my point is if that's how
you enjoy making money I'll leave you to
it but I have no problem with the fact
that Bill Gates is worth a hundred
billion dollars let's say he actually
earned it he he and his colleagues and
this created something created something
that's worth incalculable so you're
trillions and trillions of dollars of
value for the world if his share is 100
billion you're welcome to it he earns
his money but Bitcoin you don't earn
your money just take it from somebody
else in zero-sum game that adds nothing
to society no value no increase in
wealth it is gambling except there's no
casino you just take it right from the
other player there you go
so the answer there is buy gold about
ten percent and if that's what you want
to do and send it to us guys just to let
you know my show all well that ends well
which I advertised earlier the Bill
Murray that is now very close to selling
out so we've had to open up another day
I will be doing it again with Francis
emceeing again on the 24th of November
the links in the description I'm also
coming to Cambridge in in November as
well so check that out
absolutely please come down it's going
to be a great show when I'm on and then
when Constantine zone you just enjoy the
interval there is no interval by the way
so it's just the me and Francis will see
that
[Music]
let's move on to one other issue that we
wanted to discuss with you something
that you know a hell of a lot about and
we wanted to to raise with you Donald
Trump during his election campaign in
2016 spent a hell of a lot of time
talking about China he was ridiculed for
this he was mocked for this most people
who are not experts didn't even
understand why he was talking about it
somewhere in the periphery people might
have thought well he's talking about it
because a lot of manufacturing jobs have
gone to China right but if you listen to
some of his advisers if you listen to
some of the other people who talk about
the threat that China poses to the rest
of the world economically more than
anything there many more layers to it
than that
right so lay that out for us sure Trump
is a difficult to understand genius and
I look at the fact that he won in 2016
of course we're coming into the 2020
elections and I predicted the Trump
victory in 2016 so I mean that business
of predictive analytics
I have Trump as a strong favor to win
again but one of the factors I look at I
look at his opponents the media the
Democrats the progressives and I say did
they learn anything did they learn
anything in 2016 so that they can do
something different today and perhaps
beat him and so far the answer is no
they haven't learned a thing
well they've doubled down on all the
crazy cultural stuff that got him in
trouble in 2006 exactly where they've
doubled down the secure way to put but
no no son at all that that they've
learned anything but so I described
Trump's relationships with the media as
the media or herd of puppies and Trump's
the master with the red rubber ball and
he throws the ball and all the puppies
chase the ball one of them fetches it
brings it back is very good and he
throws the ball over there and they do
the same thing meanwhile he's doing
serious stuff so what's the ball yes
stormy Daniels impeachment collusion
Russia gave these things are
distractions no substance to any of them
the media keeps chasing the meanwhile
what is Trump actually doing the largest
tax cut in history he is remaking the
federal judiciary
judges at an unprecedented rate taking
control of the courts and they that's
from a list produced by the Federalist
Society
they're very staunch reliable
conservatives and they picked them in
the early 40s because it's a lifetime
appointment so you'll be on the bench 40
years from now the trunk judiciary is
going to run the United States long
after a listen after I'm gone you guys
are younger but for maybe four decades
or so in the future the Trump owns the
fed Trump came and there were two
vacancies on the Board of Governors of
the Federal Reserve why were the two
vacancies well Obama was so sure that
Hillary was going to win that he didn't
bother with the appointments he said
well I'll give him the Hillary she will
appoint some strong hands so Trump got
two seats right off the bat then there
were a couple of resignations so that
kind of went up to four seats and then
one more since then plus promoting j-pal
from a governor who where he already was
a governor before Trump to chairman so
the Lael Brainard is going to end up as
the only non Trump appointee on the
Board of Governors other federal reserve
she must feel like a hostage when she
goes into the room but the point is so
Trump owns the Federal Reserve he's
taking control of the judiciary he's
burning the Code of Federal Regulations
I mean literally burning it down so you
can actually have some freedom and the
largest tax cut in history and
confronting China and that was your
point Constantine so so the the press is
chasing the rubber ball he's doing big
stuff that's that's really gonna be
world historic so as it relates to China
so for 20 years I've seen the 1990s and
the early 2000s a little beyond that
really up until Trump the globalist view
when I say glow yeah I use these phrases
but I named names you know because we
know who these people are people like
Jeffrey Sachs at Columbia University
Richard Haass of the Council on Foreign
Relations John Kerry was our Secretary
of State and of course President Obama
and President Bush I don't see much
difference between Bush and Obama on
this point but the globalist view was
okay we know the Chinese are kind of bad
guys we know they're you know communists
but if we trade with them and open our
doors and let them break the rules and
let them steal our intellectual property
with their low-cost you know lego style
manufacturing
suddenly they'll grow rich and in the
fullness of time they'll be just like us
once they taste the fruits and the
benefits of capitalism they'll gradually
you know they may not be I get liberal
democracy the next day but they will
move away from communism and and I I
said 20 years ago I said no you've got
this exactly wrong you don't understand
the Communists and people go JM you know
the Communists it's just a couple 80 or
also in the Power Bureau they'll die
soon you know the communism is a
anachronistic in China there shouldn't
know they're hardcore communist well so
all this accommodation so yeah China in
1994 does a maxi devaluation of the yuan
2001 they joined the WTO proceeded to
break every rule in every promise it's
kind of like getting into a club and you
go you know this exclusive club you go
before the Membership Committee and they
say well we're going to admit you to the
club but you know we have a very strict
dress code you say yes I understand I'll
adhere to the dress code and you show up
the next day and like flip-flops and the
t-shirt yeah
that's China they show up in the t-shirt
and say you know give me a drink
2016 the IMF admitted them to these
small group of five currencies that are
used to calculate the value of world
money world money SDR you know the
Special Drawing rights world money
printed by the IMO but you had to make
certain promises to do that including
one that you would have an open capital
account they immediately perceived to
close the capital account in other words
China's willing to lie cheat steal we
know that but what was interesting is
that the US was willing to tolerate it
for the sake of a you know chimera or a
mirage of a more liberal China and that
hasn't happened the opposite happened
President Xi was made president for life
they had a two-term two five-year term
rotation and in your second five-year
term you had to appoint your successor
who would smoothly come in and take over
at the end of your five-year term second
five-year term that's gone she is
president for life they've now created a
new branch of ideology called gee
thought well there's only one other
dictator in China who had thought that
was mal thought Sergey is the first head
of the Communist Party since Mao Zedong
to have a school of thought named after
him
these are this is a little of Troost
perhaps
West but these are really important
things instead of inside China
so he's a head of the Communist Party
for life has his own school of thought
is suppressed all of his enemies I was
in Hong Kong not long ago a very you
know elite audience at the Asian Society
the biggest property owners scholars etc
in Hong Kong and they were all see these
people are global it sound why I get
invited to this things but they do
invite me and they're all globalist and
they're all saying nice things about
China and when it came my turn I just
looked at this one guy said what
happened to Bose Eli bozhil I was
arrival - evesham ping he was the mayor
of a head of the Communist Party of
Zhang Sheng and he was the up-and-comer
he was making his own play disappeared
we haven't heard from Bo Xilai in about
four years so he's been tortured and
sent to re-education camp they let's say
you're a Muslim we gur in western china
or you're a catholic almost anywhere in
China and in addition to having religion
because this is the officially atheist
you express a little bit of dissent
well they arrest you they put you in a
concentration camp a real one not the
made up on Samara squad in the u.s. they
it's thought reeducation so they
basically try to brainwash you into
getting with the program some people do
that or pretend to but let's say you
still don't do that you're not with the
program they strap you to an operating
table without anesthetic and they
surgically remove your organs to supply
a multi-billion dollar organ transplant
industry in China and you die having
your organs removed without anesthetic
and then they cremate the body where we
seen that before so this is China these
are your franzine atheist murderers deny
human rights drown twenty million girls
and buckets because they had the
one-child policy but everybody wanted
boys so if a girl they kept a bucket of
water by the delivery bed and if a girl
was born they drowned her on the spot so
why are we doing any business with China
that's what I don't understand and my
friend Kyle bass agrees he's been a very
successful hedge fund manager he agrees
so what Trump has done a certain job
presumably although all those things of
course terrible I don't imagine that
American voters were
turned about China on those issues you
know they were actually very concerned
about China because they were the ones
losing jobs they were the right source
of income just jobs or is it China's
trade policy what people call
mercantilism is it is is the other thing
you mentioned stealing intellectual
property tell us more about some of
those things well if you know there's
been this myth and it goes back to the
1890s when the u.s. announced the open
door policy which meant that you know we
don't we don't want to conquer you but
we were forcing you to trade with us you
know that that was the advantage for
Americans and the myth was boy so many
people in China if he could just sell
everybody one t-shirt and one bottle of
coke you'd make a fortune that has never
panned out it has never panned out so
today the moderate version of that is
boy if I could just sell everybody in
China you know one cellphone with my
patented technology or whatever but
China says sure come on and set up your
plant by the way you can only own 49% we
own 51% you have to hand over all your
patents and all your intellectual
property as the price of admission and
companies say I'm okay because I want to
sell those phones they then hand that to
Huawei which reverse engineers it puts
it in their own phones and put you out
of business that's the price of doing
business with China so a couple of
things foreign companies are waking up
to this American workers knew what a
long time ago because they were the ones
losing their jobs and you know you're
right Constantine I don't suggested
every unemployed blue-collar American
worker who lost a job the Chinese was as
concerned as I may be about human rights
violations but they're learning about
them and they're not surprised
and so Trump is the first one to stand
up to them and say no theft of
intellectual property is over investment
China is over we've weaponized certain
statutes that the United States uses to
protect our national security and it
have been on the books for a long time
but they weren't kind of strictly
enforced they've all been weaponized
today you know to say that China
couldn't buy Verizon which is one of our
biggest telecommunications companies
that's true China can't buy an ice cream
stand China can't buy anything Bob we
might as well pack up their bags and
leave they're not going to do any
business in the our States and we're
gonna see to it through Europe and Japan
and our allies that they don't do any
business with anybody else either
and if they do they can't do business in
the United States that's the secondary
broker so we're playing hardball but if
you want to boil this all down in
October 2018 our Vice President Mike
Pence gave a speech before a think tank
it's it's readily available in the
Internet and the White House website
easy to find and people are calling it
the pence doctrine it's the first time
I've ever seen Trump not name something
after himself he has to go ahead and so
it's the pence doctrine I reckon there's
a tiny room in the White House 24 we can
talk about that later
so but what what the vice president said
this is the serious party says yeah this
is a currency war this is a trade war
those important things but this is a
much bigger issue we've got human rights
violations geopolitical confrontation
the South China Sea theft of
intellectual property you know trade war
currency war and the other things we
mentioned that this is more like cold
war too doesn't mean you have a shooting
war but it means that the confrontation
is much bigger broader and will be more
long lasting and actually Pence is
preparing to deliver part two of the
pence Doctrine will be another speech
very soon and when this in my view will
be on a par with the Marshall Plan or
what's called a long telegram by George
Kennan which was turned into an article
called sources of Soviet conduct with
that article which I think came out in
1947 that could be off by a year there
abouts was the blueprint for the conduct
of u.s. foreign policy during the entire
Cold War right up until 1989 everybody
looked at that Canada article and said
yeah this is the way to do it and it
wasn't a war it was containment just
boxed up in starve them out and they
fell that's exactly what happened took
45 years but it happened this pense
doctrine is going to be the new long
telegram it's going to find our
confrontation with China and then the
thing I love is all these scholars you
know TV pundits whatever like well there
was a book and called the lucidity strap
and of course this is the Greek
historian a chronicle the
Venetia more and he said well you have
you know the established power Sparta
and the rising power Athens whenever you
happen rising power meeting and
established power they they come they
comes to award there was a war between
them and that was the history of the
Peloponnesian War so everyone's glommed
onto this and said yeah here we go again
you know the city's trap the u.s. is the
established power and China is the
rising power and it's going to come to a
confrontation there's no way around it
there may be some truth in that but what
they ignore is that sparta won in those
Athens did not win the Peloponnesian War
Sparta destroyed Athens so that would
suggest that the US will destroy China
when I could physically destroy it but
what either China will transform into a
more liberal society where the US will
box them in and defeat them at every
turn not let them steal the intellectual
property and and just to make a very
concrete US companies are already moving
the supply chain they're coming out of
China they're going into Vietnam
Indonesia Philippines Thailand Malaysia
other countries that have enough
infrastructure enough trained workers
with low wages that you can replicate
what China offers without the baggage
without the theft of intellectual
property and without supporting the
human rights violations now here's the
here's the thing
these are 10-year decisions you don't
close the plant build a new one and then
go back next year because everyone's you
know kissing and making up you move your
plan you keep it there for 10-15 years
so these jobs are coming out of China
but they're not coming back and the
Chinese economy isn't much worse that
much were saving than people realized
much more indebted much more vulnerable
and to top it off the history of China
for five thousand years is
centralization of power followed by
dissolution and decentralization then
whirring kingdoms then it centralizes
again and it falls apart again over and
over through centuries and through
dynasties right now China is at peak
centralization going back to what I said
about XI which means it's very easy to
forecast what's going to happen next its
gonna fall apart well on that happy note
we've got one more question for you Jim
well that's what is the thing that we
are not talking about
we really should be talking about the
question is when the next crisis comes
and it will come so that that's the easy
part it will be worse that's the easy
part timing hard to say and you're right
about that my answer is what are you
waiting for get ready now when it comes
what will the world look like afterwards
and I talked about this in my book in
chapter 8 and the conclusion of the book
and I suggest that there's only one
clean balance sheet left in the world
the central banks have not normalized
the balance sheets we talked about that
there is one clean balance sheet left
which is the IMF the International
Monetary Fund so just as central bank's
bail out Wall Street
perhaps the IMF will have to bail out
the central banks in other words real
iqua fie the world where's the source of
liquidity where's the money coming from
when there isn't enough but when
everyone wants their money back and
selling everything prices are crashing
money is disappearing in front of your
eyes where does the money come from to
get the system back to normal it might
only come from the IMF if they can get
their act together but they issue this
world money this SDR as they call it I
love the way they make up names that no
one understands I call the IMF
transparently non-transparent they
actually tell you what they're doing but
no one understands that it's very hard
to read but if that happens you're gonna
need China to agree and Russia to agree
in other countries that are very reverse
adversaries the United States and also
don't like the dollar so the price of
poker if you walls yeah will flood the
zone with strs will really afire the
world with world money but it means
starting now the dollar is no longer the
dominant reserve currency you know the
price of oil will be denominated in strs
the balance sheets of the hundred
largest corporations will be recorded in
STRs the SDR will be how we maintain our
reserves it doesn't mean the dollar goes
away but it becomes a local currency
like I go to Mexico you buy some pesos
you know if you visit the United States
you'll buy some dollars but it won't
play the role in place today and u.s.
power will fall with it throughout
history Rome British Empire Spanish
Empire Dutch Empire etc
when their currencies lost valued their
empires fell so they're much larger
forces in play and and what I say to
people is you know it will be the end of
the world
no but it might be almost a semi
agrarian world life might look a little
bit more like it did in 1910 well thank
you very much for coming on the show Jim
we yep there's always subscribe follow
Jim on Twitter your Twitter handle is
Jim at James G records your very active
on now follow you with great chess it's
the only social media I use but I am
fairly active right so follow Jim there
follow us at trigger Potter no social
media will put the postal address to
send all your gold in the bottom of it
and we will see you in a week
see you later guys bye bye thanks for
watching guys as always subscribe to the
YouTube channel click the bell button
next to subscribe button so you get
notified when a video comes out and
follow us on all the social media at
trigger pod and also leave us a nice
review on iTunes and spread the word